this video is sponsored by the book
summary and Discovery app blinkist use
the link in the description and you'll
receive one free week and 25 off an
annual premium membership
typically we feel as though we are in
the driver's seat we feel as though we
are in control of ourselves going where
we want for reasons that we are aware of
generally with proper attention
self-reflection and effort we can end up
places that are close enough
but if you've ever been in the driver's
seat of an actual car driving along on
an otherwise Ordinary Day in an
otherwise ordinary good mood and then
seemingly out of nowhere you had the
sudden urge even if just for a moment to
turn the car into oncoming traffic or
off a bridge or a cliff that you are
driving on then you have likely also had
the ominous visceral realization that
you are not as aware and in control of
the source of your thoughts feelings and
desires as you like to think perhaps you
are not at all in the way you like to
think
this experience might sound strange to
some people feeling an urge to turn into
traffic or drive off a cliff while
having no interest in dying or
inflicting any harm onto anyone or
anything but the phenomenon is so common
it has multiple names has been discussed
by various philosophers and
psychologists and has been researched in
several studies
the phenomenon is most commonly referred
to as the call of the Void originally a
French phrase la pel de vid more broadly
phenomena of this sort are also often
referred to as intrusive thoughts
perhaps the most common case however is
specifically known as the high place
phenomenon high place here referring
literally to the experience of being in
a high up location like the top of a
building or Cliff perhaps you have
experienced this version yourself it is
typically described as being high up
somewhere often with minimal to no guard
rails and while standing near the edge
the individual suddenly becomes
overtaken with anxiety not that wind
will blow them over nor that the ledge
is unstable and will crumble underneath
them but rather they become worried that
without their consent the brain might
decide to let or convince their body to
jump
in a 2011 study conducted at Florida
State University by psychologist Dr
Jennifer L haymes about one-third of 431
participants claimed to have experienced
this other Studies have shown that over
50 percent of people have experienced at
least aspects of this phenomenon
there are of course various ways to
consider an attempt to explain this
phenomenon Perhaps it is merely the
product of our curiosity the appeal of
something extreme that we will never
actually do we watch horror and thriller
movies partly for this exact reason to
simulate the experience of extreme and
often horrible scenarios in order to
satiate our morbid curiosity
perhaps then if this is the case we
experience the call of the Void
phenomenon because our mind is trying to
simulate what it might be like if the
worst case happened and we misunderstand
this as a desire or urge
we are inherently curious beings as
children many of us at least consider
putting our hands on a stove when we are
told that it is hot we consider putting
our fingers in electrical outlets when
we are told that they are dangerous
perhaps then as adults we consider
jumping off the ledge when we know that
it will kill us
what does that one feel like we might
wonder
it's just one step away
perhaps we are just perversely curious
to our own potential harm
maybe we do in fact partly want to know
what it feels like maybe part of us
wants it in general
alternatively referring back to the
aforementioned Florida State University
study Hames and her colleagues argued
that the phenomenon is a product of a
misinterpretation of our survival
Instinct in the high place example the
individual experiences a fear of falling
off the cliff or building and
instinctually reacts by taking the
necessary measures to avoid this this
might include things like visualizing
and Imagining the situation as well as
moving away from and avoiding the edge
the individual's conscious mind then
misinterprets and rationalizes this
response as having been an urge to jump
rather than an urge to avoid the edge
this experience has also been explored
substantially within the philosophy of
existentialism though existentialists
see it quite differently specifically
existentialist philosophers saw in
Kierkegaard and Jean-Paul Sartre both
examined and discuss the phenomenon
within their work both using the exact
example of someone being on the edge of
a building or cliff in a seminal work
being in nothingness starter describes
the experience of being in the situation
and feeling the anxiety of possibly
jumping as a result of one's realization
of their individual freedom and
responsibility
start to refer to it as the vertigo of
possibility
and kierger's work of which Sartor was
greatly influenced he similarly wrote
anxiety is the dizziness of freedom
in every moment one has the freedom to
choose to do anything that is possible
including potentially horrible things
and one is left solely to their own
devices to make these decisions or not
famously Sartor wrote man is condemned
to be free because once thrown into the
world he is responsible for everything
he does
according to Sartre as well as
Kierkegaard the human being ceaselessly
finds himself at the intersection of
infinite possibilities blind uncertainty
and personal responsibility as a result
human beings are condemned to be free as
it is a burden to bear that inevitably
produces intense anguish
both Sartor and kierogard use this high
place scenario as a way of illustrating
this on the edge of the cliff or
building one experiences the true weight
of this responsibility it is the
symbolic height of the anguish
associated with The Human Condition it
is life or death and it is always one
step away
and it is up to us to decide
building off but countering the
existentialist explanation one could
also argue that this feeling is not a
response to the realization of one's
freedom but rather the realization of
one's lack of freedom
typically in regular conditions we are
self-deluded to believe that we are in
control of mostly everything we think
and do but on the edge of the cliff
under extreme circumstances we realize
that perhaps we aren't perhaps we are
not free to do anything but rather we
are in prison to do only what we are
compelled to do by the mysterious and
complicated webbing of cause and effect
constructed by our circumstances our
genetics our moods our unconscious mind
our environment everything
in this case the feeling similarly
Springs up from the combination of
possibility and uncertainty mirroring
the existentialist view but dissimilarly
it is not the uncertainty of what we
will do with our freedom but it is the
uncertainty of what we will do because
of our lack of Freedom or free will
the uncertainty of our impulses and
feelings and thoughts that seemingly
always just appear in our consciousness
of which we never really know or control
until we've already thought felt or
acted on them if part of us had the
thought of jumping could part of us act
on it as well
even if we never would and our conscious
filter always Catches Us perhaps the
call of the Void is so unsettling
because it is a rare Moment of clarity
into this avoid in our own psychology
there is relatively little research on
the call of the void and even less
certainty around an explanation perhaps
the void is not merely at the foot of
the cliff or the building or whatever
else perhaps rather it is in US
an opening or gap between what we know
about ourselves and what we don't what
we feel we control about ourselves and
what we don't
regardless of the reason and explanation
once we've heard the call of the Void we
must live with the strange echo of a
voice that came from us but isn't ours
this video was sponsored by blinkist
exploring these sorts of philosophical
and perhaps darker topics like the call
of the Void can be extremely fascinating
useful liberating poignant cathartic and
so on but of course it's also important
that we make sure we spend time and
attention on other areas on the surface
of Our Lives things like our overall
health relationships career daily
routine and so on a great way to do this
is with blinkist an app that allows you
to understand the most important ideas
from over 5 500 non-fiction books and
podcasts across 27 different categories
all in just 15 minutes a great book to
help you keep your head on straight in
the strange existence is unwinding
anxiety by Judson Brewer which is
extremely useful for understanding the
origins of addictive obsessive and
unwanted thought patterns and most
importantly how to interrupt and
untangle these patterns to retrain our
mind and move away from unnecessary
anxiety blinkus provides a great
breakdown of this title which like all
titles on their platform can be both
read or listened to even while offline
making it easy to discover and learn new
insights whenever and wherever you are
and now through blinkist connect premium
users can also share their account with
one other person at no additional cost
allowing you to share your favorite
selected books with someone close
discover new books and new Authors
refresh yourself on important books
you've already read and accelerate your
understanding of new complex ideas
wherever and whenever click the link in
the description or scan the QR code on
the screen and enjoy two memberships for
the price of one a seven day free trial
and 25 off blink is premium
and of course as always thank you so
much for watching in general and see you
next video
[Music]